- I'm lucky enough to be
very restless, some people
call it ADD.
The economy's bad and I'm
not going to get a job, well
tough (bleep).
School's like a system isn't it?
And for me, I couldn't do
it their way, I'm a third
grade speller, I had to do it my way.
What always baffled me is
why I didn't have more people
across the street competing with me.
And I would say if you're
not drinking enough beer
at the Oasis you're not taking
advantage of your education.
If you're always what you
didn't do yesterday, you're
never ready to do today's
work, let alone tomorrow's.
The only reason you have
management is to remove
obstacles, not to make obstacles.
You know the secret
elixir of life is sleep.
I had to trust people, I
trusted people because I wasn't
capable of doing things myself.
You can't lead other people
unless you manage yourself.
- He co-founded the copy chain
Kinko's, Fortune Magazine
named Kinko's to be one of
the best places in America
to work for three years in a row.
Now that he is no longer the
CEO of Kinko's he's focused
his efforts on philanthropy,
he's Paul Orfalea and
her are his top ten rules for success.
(wooshing sound)
- I'm lucky enough to be
very restless, some people
call it ADD and I was very
good at leading my business.
After the first three months
we hired a manager because
those stores used to drive
me nuts, they were very
hectic and nerve-wracking.
And my job was really, because
of my restlessness, I could
be in the moment, was going
store to store to store
looking for what people are
doing right and exploiting it.
Couldn't I make a lot more
money discovering some cool
new idea than hovering in that
office worrying about stuff?
And I was working with very
capable people that knew
how to run the business very well.
I did financial controls but
my job was always looking
for ideas to make it better.
And I always had to define
my job that everything
went beautifully without
me, but whatever I did
every day I made it better.
You're surrounded by success,
thinking about a washing
machine, washing machine
weighs maybe 150 pounds, you
buy it for $750?
Isn't that an amazing thing? $5 a pound?
You get all those little
parts, that for some reason
seems to break.
Isn't that kind of an amazing
thing how you get that
whole washing machine for $5 a pound?
Isn't that kind of a cool deal?
Are you aware that you
are surrounded by success?
Every time you're buying
something, it's a successful
endeavor, do you see the
success around you and are
you obsessed with making money
from the success around you?
Are you obsessed with what's wrong?
Like you can sit in your
office, now you all have a
great cop out, the economy's
bad and I'm not going to
get a job, well tough (bleep)
you've got that cop out
for the rest of your life.
That's not going to be, you
want to have that you can
intellectually be very honest
and you can sit at the Oasis
and just become an alcoholic.
(audience laughing)
I mean really, you have
that intellectual option
because you say the job
market's bad, I'm just going to
go to depression, isn't that fear?
That's an honest response
and I would say maybe you
ought to just think about
all the gifts you have and
say the world is successful,
I want to be part of it.
But I don't want to work
for other people, maybe?
That's like think why
you're here, is that right?
I'm really lucky, I can't read
well, I have no mechanical
ability, I was held back
from two grades, I was
expelled from four high
schools, I was graduated
8th from the bottom of my class of 1,200.
I figured out how to go
through college because I
didn't really want to get
drafted and if you think of
it school's like a system, isn't it?
And for me, I couldn't do
it their way, I was a third
grade speller, I had to do it my way.
And I think that getting
through that system prepares
you for life and how to
get through that system.
When you think of it, business
is really defining making
your own rules to a certain extent.
I don't know nowadays if
rejection is part of your
every day life, so I think
a lot of business and
doing things is just the
idea of having resilience.
I'm going to ask you all a
question, if you're little five year
old comes to you with a
painting from school, what are
you going to say?
(audience talking)
Absolutely, the worst thing
you could say because what
you do by saying good job is
you teach a child to please
others rather than to please themselves.
What you might want to say
is tell me about the painting
and why did you do it?
But I think to produce, I
don't know if today people
are risk takers, they want a
lot of atta boys and you have
to give it to them sooner or later.
So I'm not sure, can I
amplify it a little bit?
- Absolutely, please.
- Here I am, I'm at USC and
it's really not complicated,
I saw all these people in line
Xeroxing, what a discovering.
If they're Xeroxing at USC,
why wouldn't they Xerox
at Santa Barbara?
Was this, such research, I
didn't invent the Xerox machine,
they were just in line
Xeroxing and at one point, all
the customers could see,
I had all the customers in
line, my own workers could see
how much money I was taking
in and I wasn't, we expanded
every college in America.
What always baffled me, is
why I didn't have more people
across the street competing
with me and I think even
back then we weren't risk
takers but look back on
your grandparents, if your
grandparents had seen that I had
something good with customers
lining, you think they
would have been out there
competing with me in
a heartbeat?
So, I'm not sure risk taking
is as rewarded as it should be.
You fall in love with
somebody here, you don't love
them here what happens?
You get a stomach ache here,
where do you fall in love?
With your stomach.
(audience laughing)
Are you cultivating your intuition?
And I would say if you're
not drinking enough beer at
the Oasis, you're not taking
advantage of your education.
(audience laughing)
Because what you're going to
do in life is you're always
going to be gauging people
if they're bs'ers or not.
And if you're not cultivating
your human skills they're
going to snow you, you know what I mean?
Drinking beer is not your
enemy, drinking beer is
socializing, having coffee,
you're learning that those
are very constructive moments,
you're learning is that
a person to bs or could I trust them?
What is the behavior that I
really want for my workers?
If you're always doing what
you didn't do yesterday,
you're never ready to get
to do today's work, let
alone tomorrow's.
I was always in the moment
looking for opportunities,
I was always at Kinko's,
the guy across the street,
looking at my business.
I was never really in the
business looking out and if you
have that vantage point,
first of all you're healthy
paranoid, you deal with
anxiety, you're always on
the cutting edge of making it better.
And I simplify my job is
everything went beautifully
without me but whatever I did
every day I made it better.
I sold my business to these
guys in New York, they asked
me my biggest competitive
advantage and I said it was
the sparkle in our workers
eyes and I firmly believe that.
Cuz anybody can have those
silly little Xerox machines, but
what really made the
competitive advantage was our
workers had a sense of
purpose, and they've got
a thousand thank yous from
customers and they're really
working for the customer, they
could see that relationship.
So I really spent all my time
nurturing that relationship
and the best definition of
management came from my wife,
the only reason you have
management is to remove
obstacles, not to make
obstacles so the only purpose
of a owner or a manager is
to make worker's jobs simpler
and eaiser and that's how
I conducted my affairs.
Get a good night's sleep,
you know the secret elixir of
life is sleep, everybody
wants this natural everything,
why don't you just try a good
night's sleep for a change.
And you know, what you've
learned in the daytime is
imprinted on your brain
while you sleep, so if you're
not getting a good night's
sleep you're not taking
advantage of your education.
My mom only cared about two
things, saving and sleeping.
(audience chuckling)
That's the only two things,
I don't care what you're
doing, you're going to bed
early and you're getting
a good night's sleep, your
grades aren't as important
as a good night's sleep.
The only thing you have
to trust, what is the most
important thing a child wants?
Predictable environment
from their mother, that's
called trust.
What's the only thing you
want from a teenager? Trust.
want from a worker? Trust.
Doesn't the worker say,
well I want to trust that
you can pay me?
Trust is all qualities of
leadership, isn't that when
you break someone's trust?
Life is all about trust,
there's only one word and so
I had no choice, as much
as I'm paranoid, I had
to trust people.
I trusted people because
I wasn't capable of doing
things myself.
We had to incorporate in the
philosophy of our company,
the values, the real value
statement of what we were
all about, the idea of
work, love, and play.
To be successful in life you
have to have three things
in balance, if not how would
you run a 24 hour a day
business?
If you didn't have a
balance in your life, you
following me?
I mean, you'd have a
nervous breakdown if you're
just a workaholic, wouldn't you?
So I think to be successful
you have to have all
three and you'll be more
successful if you strive for
balance in your life.
You'll make better decisions,
somehow wives really
ground the hell out of
you, you're not a big shot
at home and that's good.
(audience chuckling)
So just try to remember,
make goals every year for
all three, work, love, and
play and it's just important.
You'll make better decisions.
Imagine when I went out and
I told these people that
love things, let's go 24
hours a day, what they would
say to me?
Paul, I can't work any harder,
how do you expect me to
keep this thing open 24 hours a day?
Those are the wrong people,
they had a idea of going
to people based people and
you can't lead other people
unless you manage yourself.
If you don't look rested,
nobody wants to follow a
leader that's tired,
haggard, and miserable.
It's just not a
prerequisite for leadership.
Nobody wants to, I think Obama's
done a bad job, the first
month he looked too dour, I
voted for him, but I agree
with Bill Clinton, he is not.
Yesterday he was inspirational,
but you don't want the
President of the United States
saying if you don't pass
this legislation you'll go with the cliff.
Wrong, he's got to always be
cheerful, always uplifting,
that's what leaders are
supposed to do and then
somebody said, "Well you
want him to be honest."
No, you don't always have
to be honest as a leader,
you could honestly say I know
this problem's over there
but we're still going to charge forward.
You don't have to, leadership
is a different thing.
It's not you open (foreign term)
remember work, love, and
play you'll be successful.
You'll be a better leader,
you'll be a more balanced
person and people will respect you more.
So all you workaholics, drink some beer.
(audience laughing)
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because
girohead asked me to, or girohead?
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it in
the comments below and I'll
see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Paul's top ten rules
meant the most to you,
leave it in the comments
and we'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe
and I'll see you soon.
(wooshing sounds)
- It's astounding at
the lack of knowledge of
current events, I teach
at USC, in my own class.
Give them a little
current events test in the
beginning, two students
this last few weeks ago,
they were 2200 in the SAT
types, solid As, native
Californians, couldn't
point Arizona on the map.
The guy said it's sort of in this area.
How do you not know where Arizona is?
(audience laughing)
Do you think that if you
didn't know where Arizona
was you might have had that
straight A education but
you got in the lunch room and
they're going to say fired.
What do you think?
I mean there's just certain
things, I mean how many
of you knew last summer there
was a flood in Pakistan?
What are you going to talk
about when you get out in
the real world if you
don't have any knowledge
of current events?
How do you have any way of
assimilating your education
in some sort of context if
you don't have a knowledge
of current events?
I was always a current events
junkie, I'd go home at 4:00
and watch news until 7:00.
Maybe I took it to the
extreme, but I wake up in the
middle of the night and I
watch the BBC for five minutes
to find out what the hell's
gone on since I went to bed.
I'm really curious.
(audience laughing)
You ever read a good book,
you just can't wait for
the next chapter?
Never happened to me,
but I hear you can do it.
(audience laughing)
But the news is like that.
- So you heard from Mr.
Orafalea himself, my students,
be curious, pay attention.
- And watch the paper, read
the paper, read the news.
Be involved.
You want to hear another
great stupid story?
(audience laughing)
They got his McKinsey, you
ever heard of McKinsey?
(audience laughing)
Are they here or something?
So I leave the company, they
spent $2 million to study
our business, okay?
I was talking to this man
and he owned these markets
called (bleep) Markets in
Pennsylvania, you ever see them?
Okay, guy tells me at lunch,
you know I can't explain
it but we would close our
business from midnight to 6 in
the morning cuz we'd only
do $40 in business but our
daytime business would drop in half.
He said I don't understand why
just closing those six hours
would have such an effect
on my daytime business.
What did the guy tell
you, I go to bed, I go to
sleep I wake up like a bat
out of hell and I said,
what'd the guy tell you,
if you go 24 hours a day,
your daytime business
doubles, is that correct?
And it's true, and it
doubled, my overhead was the
same everything, it was
all marginal profit.
Was that a cool discovery?
Let's go like this, yeah
it was a good discovery.
(audience laughing)
So the bozos get this
McKinsey in there and McKinsey
takes a stopwatch and says
by the way you'll save
a bunch of money closing
at 10 at night and opening
up at 6 in the morning.
Was the wrong decision?
You know the art of business
is seeing what isn't there,
anybody can see what's
there but the art is seeing
what isn't there.
Did anybody see that half
the customers I lost cuz I
wasn't there?
But that's another thing that
maybe you guys don't see,
you don't see what isn't there.
Maybe you should go home
and have some more anxiety.
There's only one measure
of success in this world.
You know what that is?
Do your children want to be
with you when they're adults?
Don't forget, if you get so
busy your children don't ever
want to come home and see
you, I don't know if that's
really being successful, so
it's very tricky marketing
to your kids cuz you want
to raise them and be strict
but at the same time you
want them to come home for
Christmas.
How do you do that?
If you become too strict they
don't want to come home ever?
You're a jerk, if you're
too lenient they become
drug addicts, I don't know.
(audience laughing)